the biggest mistake that I have done in
my entrepreneurial career I'm going to
walk through and then I'll explain kind
of the The Meta concept that I think is
why we are doing better now than we've
ever done before the very beginning of
my business I started an online uh
Fitness coaching business called the
free training project which then flipped
to for-profit I then started a gym now I
did a smart move and said I'm going to
focus on only one of them which was the
gym and the gym grew I kept doing this
gym thing cuz that kept working and then
all of a sudden as I kept opening
locations I was like man I'm pretty good
at this marketing and sales stuff then
all these people started being like hey
can I give you money to do other stuff
and I was like well I accept money and I
can do other things so that sounds great
within the next 12 months I had a dental
agency a Ciro agency and a business that
was the turnaround business which was me
flying out to gyms and so I tried to
grow four businesses at the same time
where I was CEO of all of them it took
me getting into a head-on collision in a
DUI where I had a mentor of mine
whatever you want to call it who's like
your lack of ability to make decisions
will kill you after that over the next 7
days I broke up with which is probably
the best term because some of you guys
are in terrible Partnerships and won't
admit it I broke up with my partner um
that I had with a couple of the gyms not
all of them but a couple of them I broke
up with partner I had for dentl a part
broke up with a partner I had for Cairo
and then broke up with another business
that was related to tangentially with
the launch thing and it sucked but
finally after all of those conversations
I was able to just do the turnaround
business and then within the next
however many months you guys know that
story it exploded we made a whole bunch
of money and then we switched to
licensing and then we did uh 3 something
then 480 then 780 then a million then
one2 then 15 then two and we kept going
straight line all the way to four at
that point I was like huh you know what
we could do start another business that
was when I started Prestige and Prestige
obviously helped the top line and the
bottom line as well but the day that I
started Prestige was the day that gym
launch stopped growing so gym launch
maintained and then I grew Prestige cuz
then Prestige got all my reign then I
was like okay well I split my attention
we went up in Revenue well I'm going to
create this ecosystem for gyms and so
then I started Allen and so I'm now here
with three companies I just have more
money to do things now and so I'm CEO of
Allen CEO of prestige labs and CEO of
gym lunch and as soon as that happened
um Prestige Labs went down slowly and
gym launch went down very very very
slowly and that continued until I sold
Allan and then after I sold Allen gym
launch straight line
up and that was what allowed us to
actually eventually exit the company I
bring this up because it's been the
hardest lesson of my entrepreneurial
career you have to learn to say no and I
actually think Focus just comes down to
saying no to everything that is not what
you said you would
do that's it that's all it
is and so if we want to be focused then
you can run that filter through your
brain which is this is something that is
not what I said I would do which means
if I want to be focused the answer is no
now how focused you are determines the
extent to which and across domains that
you say no to so on one level you say no
to business
opportunities even more focused to be a
person who says no to business
opportunities and new friend
opportunities even more focused to be
somebody who does no new friend
opportunities no new business
opportunities no networking
opportunities and the list can keep
going right if somebody did literally
nothing else then they'd be the most
focused person and so it's not a am I
focused or not it's how focused are you
there's this quote that I heard from
Justine musk which is Elon musk's like
seventh wife removed or whatever Elon if
you ever see this I love you she said he
said no in a way that protected his
resources so that he could Channel them
towards his own goal and I realized that
behind every no is a deeper yes to
whatever it is that you
do and so I just think about it that way
which is like the focus feels bad on the
outside because no one likes saying no
but what it really is just saying yes
again to the thing you said you would do
and the reason this is so near and dear
to my heart is because I have it's it's
been the struggle of my life it's been
so hard for me and the opportunities
that I get presented now are insane
they're nuts and I recently had to turn
down an opportunity that was absolutely
absurd and now the opportunities are all
billion dollar opportunities
everything's a billion now which is cool
but I also have acquisition. comom which
will for sure be a billion dollar plus
company in the next 36 months like we
will be there that's like we need to we
didn't we need to not do anything else I
can just not mess it up and it's still
hard and so I gave myself this saying
which was and you can scale it up or
down whatever way you want which is I'm
not going to sacrifice my first billion
for my second
and so right now some of you have your
first million or 10 million or 100
million or whatever the number is for
you and you get excited about your
second 100 million or your second 10
million or your second million and you
forget to make your first one and I'm
I'm keep I have so much content on this
specific topic because it's something I
struggle with so much and that's why I
wanted to hit on this so you're going to
hear another quote so you guys can tell
me who this is uh people think Focus
means saying yes to the thing you focus
on you've got to focus on but that's not
what it means at all means saying no to
100 other good ideas that there are you
have to pick carefully I'm actually as
proud of the things we haven't done as
the things I have done Innovation is
saying no to a thousand things Steve
Jobs you've got to say no no no and when
you say no you piss people off also
Steve Jobs I was listening to an
interview from one of his Executives
when they were building the um the I
can't remember if was the iPod or the
iPhone and so they were like so what was
it like to work with Steve and he said
Steve would start meetings and just say
what have you said no to lately you just
start with that because he figured out
that that's what Focus really meant is
what you say no to and he said I would
sometimes like have some NOS ready for
the meeting so I could like throw him
out but he's like he wouldn't be
satisfied if I gave him like obvious NOS
he said it had to be no to something
that you deeply wanted it had to be like
a juicy no and some of you guys right
now have juicy NOS that are sitting
there and you just have to get the
credit from Steve Jobs for saying a real
no cuz the other aren't actually NOS
they're obvious Nos and if you actually
pursued them you'd be an idiot the ones
that really are the meaningful ones that
Propel you in your career are also these
sacrifices that you put on the altar of
the success that you want to have and so
in some ways it's like it's it's all the
opportunities that you turn away because
you really thought about the one thing
that you that meant that meant the most
to you and so I got this from a mentor
he said if you don't say no to good
opportunities you'll never have the time
to pursue the Great opportunities'
and once in a lifetime opportunities
come about twice a year so let me
explain why this concept matters and why
it's going to make you more money and
why I think it's the greatest superpower
of
entrepreneurs so fundamentally you can
do more stuff or get more for the stuff
you do that's it which is fundamentally
volume times leverage this is the
definition of output which I Define work
as output personally so I don't Define
it as you know work times distance times
whatever in within the context of a
business it's the amount of stuff you do
and what you get for every repetition
which yields your ultimate output so in
the beginning when you're really shitty
at making cold calls you have to do a
lot of them to get and you don't have a
lot of Leverage because you're bad at it
to get some level of output but here's
the really interesting thing about
leverage and volume the more you do the
better you get at doing I've told this
story before and there's a lot of
different analogies for it but two
classes start in University for making
one class the professor says you have to
make the perfect pot by the end of the
semester it's the only assignment you
make one pot and at the end I'll grade
you on how good that pot is the other
group he said I don't care how good the
pots are make as many pots as you
possibly can and I'm just going to
measure it and the pot has to be round
and it has to be able to hold water and
that's it those are the requirements of
the pot as many as you can and at the
end of the semester everyone assumed
that the person who had the quality pot
was going to be one who had the best pot
and the volume pots had the most volume
pots but something interesting happened
which is that the people with the volume
pots had both the most pots and the best
pots because they had so many more
repetitions to get better they had done
more work and they got better at what
they did and so then they had literally
far more output and the quality was
better so they crushed the other team if
it was a business Bruce Lee said I don't
fear the man who's done 10,000 kicks one
time I fear the man who's done one kick
10,000 times and so some of you are just
doing one kick at a time which are your
business ventures and you as
entrepreneurs are just like wondering
why your kick suck it's like because
they're always new and it's starting a
game over with a different character
every time you get to level two and
saying well I'm going to see if I can
beat level one yet again with this new
character and then you get stuck yet
again I'm partially saying this because
I'm trying to reinforce this with myself
because saying no to that last billion
dollar opportunity just recently I said
no to so I made a video
um a while ago about a billion dollar
opportunity I said no to a really big
one was far more than a billion dollar
opportunity like this week and so this
is me rededicating to the fact that the
woman in the red dress just gets hotter
and hotter and hotter it never goes away
or at least it hasn't gone away for me
if you continue to grow if you stay the
same then you know the woman of the red
dress or if you go down the woman of red
dress gets uglier right I say this
figuratively what's interesting about
this is that I actually think the
distractedness comes from a place of
delusion it's that we somehow fool
ourselves into thinking that if we do
two things we can compete against people
who do one thinking that we're that much
better than the competition and we're
just not because the person who's going
to beat you is the person who said no to
everything else imagine the perfect
competitor somebody that you would be
incredibly afraid to go up against
they're incredibly intelligent they're
incredibly hardworking they always learn
from their mistakes they never stop they
say no to nothing
else be a tough person to compete
against and then add on top of the fact
that they're patient and they have no
rush to beat
you probably going to win here's the
interesting thing you can be that
competitor like I mean I think about
myself when I had I had I if you count
each location as a location I had like
10 businesses I was CEO of if you don't
count the locations then I had four
different businesses that I was CEO of
it was absurd Not only was I just the
CEO I was also the chief salesman for
like half of them like and also did the
delivery like it was a period of time
where I did not sleep I did not eat I
did not work out I mean I kind of worked
out cuz Lea fores me too and she feeds
me so I ended up staying in okay shape
but anyways point is is that I was only
alive on like I was like hooked up to
Just Energy drinks and adrenaline hoping
to make this thing work and the harder I
work the less money I made because I was
doing it
wrong and I'm hoping that I can prevent
one person here from doing that and so
saying no as I try to see this now is
saying is putting money in the bank
saying yes spends the money and I think
we want to say yes because yes is feel
good in the moment and feel bad later
when you have to stick with that
commitment NOS feel bad today because
you have to let someone down but feel
good later when you realize you don't
have to go or you don't have to do that
thing that you almost had to do and so
it's actually Nos and yeses are very
short-term long term in terms of
decision making so I was like why do we
keep doing this or we Royal we why do I
keep doing this um and so trying to zero
that down has helped me um and just
saying like oh this is you being wanting
a cookie today that's why you're trying
to say yes you just want a cookie right
now and simplifying it like that has
helped me get over it well I mean I you
know once an addict always an addict for
you know distracted Focus uh but for now
I've have conquered my my addiction for
the the week um and so you know the
reason people can't say no is because
saying yes once you start takes less
effort it gives reward now and pain
later no gives pain now and reward
later and I think where this really
comes down is that our business when it
gets tough stops rewarding you because
like when things are growing it's
exciting of course it's like a new
relationship you're like super you know
you're into it things are moving
momentum's happening you're hiring
people there's cash flow it's great but
then all of a sudden you encounter this
boss or this obstacle this thing that
you can't get over and all of a sudden
like all that reward starts going away
or becoming far more infrequent and so
then you your eye starts wandering and
you start looking for the other
relationship that high again um but
trying to reframe that point as I am at
level three and it doesn't matter how
many new characters I switch to I'm
going to have to battle this boss and so
all I'm doing is delaying the inevitable
for a confrontation that I have to have
to do thinking about it that way has
basically made me be like don't be
little [__] like you have to frame and
this is a useful exercise for anyone is
I try and frame the thing that I don't
know how to the problem as something I
don't know how to do so rather than
saying who had the ads problem you guys
so instead of saying ads agencies don't
work I'm not saying you say this instead
of saying ad agencies don't work you say
I don't know how to work with ad
agencies that is a skilled deficiency
and now it's under your control right
and so blame becomes something that you
can control and then now you can do
something about it I promise there are
agencies that do a good job in your
space the same thing is like um Tik Tock
doesn't work for us I don't know how to
work Tik Tok this is a skill deficiency
and if that's what I need to do for the
the next level rather than starting
another business and reconquering the
first three because I can get to that
level really quickly and get that quick
High I have to sit here and I have to be
comfortable in the fact that I don't
know what I'm
doing and the problem with that period
is that you basically have to try out
all of your best bad ideas until you
have no bad ideas left and you have only
good ones and so and then one of those
good ones will work and sometimes it
takes five best bad ideas to get to a
sixth good idea but once you have that
sixth what's interesting about it is
that like you've seen before once you
unlock level three you know how to pass
it every time and so I would say that
the reason that we've been able to move
so quickly now with the companies that
we have that we invest in that we buy is
that we know what level you know one
through 100 million a year looks like
and now we're about to you know cross
our third company doing that and so like
we we we've done this before now and I
remember I think I was telling somebody
the story but when I was trying to find
a sales director for the first time I
had no idea what I was looking for so
the first thing I did was the first
mistake everyone makes which is oh this
guy's the best guy on the team I'll make
him the manager don't do that I did that
and then of course I lost my best closer
and my best closer also hated managing 0
for two and so then I'm like okay I
either have to give him a demotion which
is going to hurt his ego right just it's
just terrible rocking hard place so so
that didn't work out so then I hired
another sales manager this sales manager
was the opposite of that guy all
operations all process and he did
mediocre to bad better than the guy who
hated people and just wanted to close
deals who's a pure Hunter this guy did
okay eventually we said Hey how do you
think you're doing and he's like not
that good and we're like okay you can
either leave or we can take the demotion
he was like I will swallow my pride and
take the demotion I'd rather just close
and I was like great so then I had a
third sales manager and this guy l
people and he understood sales well and
so he loved spending time doing 10 ones
he loved watching the guys improve he
was just a people person and he was
organized and he trained the team and
the team's performance went up and I was
like oh that's what a sales director
looks like and from that point in my
career I haven't missed on sales
directors and that has been true of
every every other role I've had in the
business and so all of the time that it
took for for those managers to cycle
through was growth I didn't have close
rates that dropped cash flow that
suffered
because I didn't know what it looked
like and so I consider that ignorance
debt and so we have to pay that debt
down so all businesses incur debt and
the biggest one being ignorance of the
founder not knowing what it takes to
grow this business and
so framing the problems that we have as
the things that we have to confront as
this is debt I have to pay and there's
no way around it this is a toll of the
success road that I'm on and I will stay
at this toll until I come up with the
change to pay this debt to open the
lever so I can go to the next toll booth
and keep driving until I hit it again
and it's going to cost me probably more
at the next one because these guys are
greedy these told these uh you know the
lessons of Life are very
expensive and so for me the reason I
spend so much time documenting a lot of
you guys probably don't know this but my
podcast when I started it I didn't make
it for you guys I made it for
me and for those of you who are trying
to like document your journey really
helpful frame because I didn't really
get too obsessed with the fact that I
had like 200 downloads per episode like
it didn't really matter to me cuz I was
like you know it'd be cool cuz one of
the biggest things I always wanted was
Elon Musk and Jeff basos the channel
from 1997 where he's like here I am on
Amazon and this is our sign and we'll
see what happens and I wish that they
had done that and so I've tried very
hard to be able to do that um you know
with my own career and so for those of
you who want a fun little tidbit the
first podcast that I have is 90 days
after after I lost
everything so you can actually hear from
basically Ground Zero to here now the
evolution and thinking so and I think
that there might be some utility in that
because as I'm walking through that it's
at zero so what I'm thinking with is an
entrepreneur who just lost everything is
trying to figure out what the next move
is and so use that for what you will but
from a Content perspective I try and
document those lessons so that I can
continually recognize the pattern again
and so what I want to have happen is oh
this is another one of those and then I
can just play The Playbook I be like
what did I what was I thinking then and
I can go back into the archives and be
like Oh yeah this is what I'm looking
for oh yeah this is what I'm looking for
two biggest regrets I have is that I
didn't document anything until I lost
everything twice number one the second
biggest regret that I have is that I
have no recorded sales from the 4,000
closes that I did in person not one to
be fair Tech wasn't as good then it
would have been a little bit weird but I
could have done
it and I regret that I mean imagine the
[__] Library I would have had and so
I hope that you do that but what I want
you to have is I want you to have your
your playlist of your hottest calls if
you are a salesperson or have great
salese having them record when they're
hot when you're like dude I could close
anyone right now that's what you want to
record because the way that you pause
how you phrase your questions your
tonality everything is what it's like to
be on fire and being on fire is simply a
different way of doing things that you
were before that's more effective and so
so what you want to do is then study why
what is it and how I talk and how I
phrase these words that increases the
close rate of my calls what is it and
then you can get better and better and
better at closing because you'll study
the best game footage you'll repeat the
most successful activities that you did
advantages of saying no to everything is
actually keeping a deep
yes because the best person in the world
has only done that thing their entire
lives and that's how you get world class
results the biggest Returns come from
the end of the cycle what I mean by
this and this is kind of the unfortunate
or fortunate part of life is that if you
think about this as your progress right
so let's say this is 10% 20% 30% 40% 50%
60% 70% 80% right that's you compared to
the rest of the
marketplace you get better this whole
time and you barely see any improvements
in output but all the gains come from
being the top 10% to the top 5% all of
this gain becomes yours and then top
five to top 97 A2 all of that becomes
yours and you gain more from getting
from 95 to 97 A2 than you did from
everything up to 90 because fortunately
unfortunately we live in a winter take
all society and so if you look at the
top selling book on Amazon it sells more
than the bottom 5.9 million books on
Amazon
Amazon and when you buy stuff on Amazon
you probably like oh there's three
products here one that has 2,000 reviews
one that has 200 and one that has 20
you're not like you know what I'm going
to chance it on the
200 you're like I'm feeling risky today
no you just buy the 2,000 why because
it's trusted and that's how most people
do it and that's why the sales are
distributed 95% and then for some reason
someone doesn't like the color of the
main seller and or their phone didn't
load weird and they accidentally click
the number two best seller right and you
got lucky and so what's interesting
about this period right here and I'm I'm
starting to really live that right now
and I'm trying to like send telegrams
back so that hopefully it's helpful is
that if you make a video 10% better you
don't get 10% more
views sometimes you get five times the
views if you make a video 20% better
you'll get 50 times the views and so we
get outsize returns for incremental
improvements
here and the only way you can get those
incremental improvements is saying no to
everything that isn't the one thing that
matters most so I think some of you guys
have some juicy nose sitting on your
table at home I think you have some
strategic decisions that aren't really
strategic decisions they're things that
just take up all your time when you
could just be working on the stuff that
you know will grow your business which
is do more do better period
and you don't need to try that new thing
you probably don't need to go to that
random lunch with so and so to explore
synergies I know who you are and I'll
tell you a fun story to drive this home
so um recently there was a relatively
large influencer who reached out to me
and lots of following blah blah blah
you'd know who they were and um they
were like hey I would love to connect
and I was
like this will not change anything about
what my plan is to grow
acquisition. and I fundamentally have
always held the belief that if I
continue to grow a that door will either
be open or there will be a bigger and
better door that will open in that
door's place if it closes because people
will always want to make room for
winners and winners have to say no to
everyone else
Joe Rogan can call anybody to get them
to answer his call and if he said no to
them 10 years ago do you think it's more
or less likely that they answer the call
when he calls them now more likely but
if Joe Rogan had taken every one of
those calls and not built The Joe Rogan
Experience the way it is now many of
those people probably wouldn't answer
their calls and so when people are
trying to connect with you because of
the success you have realize that it's
because of the Su success you have and
they will only want to reach out to you
more when when you have even more
success and so you actually threaten the
main reason they reached out to you by
choosing to take the call and so this
particular individual he like well you
know maybe we can you know I have the
deal that you could blah I was like all
right maybe this could contribute and
says I am free on Monday at this time
he's like well I'm not free at that time
and I said okay and he's like I'm not
free on Mondays and I was like well I
take calls on Mondays he was like well
um well I mean can you change it to any
of the other days of the week and I said
no
he just kind of like got
weird and so then I was like I guess we
won't
meet and I can keep living my life
because I know what I need to do right
now to get us to where we want to go and
there's probably nothing that this
person is going to say that is going to
in any way increase the likelihood that
that
occurs and so thinking about it from
like how will this change my activities
help at least does for me say no to the
hundreds and thousands of things that
want to take your attention and you just
have to make the decision of whether you
care about that thing more than you care
about feeling good in the moment or
Saving Face and I would strongly
recommend as fast as seemly possible
being okay with people not liking you
not understanding you and thinking that
you are different than them because you
are you're a
winner H yeah I'll take let's take I got
a little time so let's um uh shoot why
can I ask why did you say to the billion
dollar deal if that wouldn't that
contribute to the big U the way that
that deal would work it would require
more time for me to not be doing this
that deal though it has a risk adjusted
return of a billion plus now decreases
the likelihood that I make this billion
plus which has a far higher likelihood
this one is I don't want to say
nothing's guaranteed in life but I don't
have need to believes like with every
new venture there's a certain number of
need to beliefs like if this happens and
this happens and this happens then we
can achieve this thing if I've already
netted out the need to beliefs like we
need to believe that if we make content
that we can make content that spreads to
business owners that was a need to
belief I didn't have that when I started
acquisition. comom so I paid down that
risk by starting but it turns out that
if you make business owner content
business owners pay attention check now
from business owner content does that
then create demand for deals I don't
know some people just watch stuff and
nothing happens it turns out that if you
do make business owner content even if
you give away all the secrets business
owners are more likely not less likely
to want to do business with you I didn't
know that that was a guess check that
worked and so there's just this number
of need to believes that occurs in every
single business if you don't know what
these are for you highly recommend
figuring with those out because then you
can ask the question differently which
is does this increase the likelihood
that what I want to have happen happens
and then that can approximate a
confidence score which is how confident
am I in taking this action which is
what's the perceived likelihood of me
getting what I want or what I think will
happen and so most entrepreneurs by
Nature are optimistic we think
everything's going to work out and then
all of a sudden everyone here many
people every time I ask this question
more than half the room says they're
stuck so obviously it didn't and so we
have to balance this eternal optimism
which keeps you going with the crushing
real reality of the fact that we don't
guess that well and we have to solve new
problems because we don't have the
perspective from which to make the
judgment when we started you probably
know a hundred times more about the
business now than when you did the back
of napkin math and you're like I'm going
to be rich right and there's all these
other things but the thing is is that
they are now known unknowns when you
have an opportunity you go into unknown
unknowns because you don't have
perspective because you're not in it all
you have to do side note is talk to
people who are in that game for five
plus years and they will tell you all
the problems in the business yes so I
have the construction company I have a
flipping business um and I also about to
start building like literally three
houses how did you
identify uh you know gym launch as your
wife how do you know it's your wife or
just another woman in the red dress so
I'm going to read this quote from the um
founder of uh Dropbox Drew Houston he
said everyone loves the idea of focus
but what Focus actually means is
shooting stuff you love and turning down
things you know you can make work and so
you all three of those businesses you
can probably make work or they already
are so for me this is actually my really
good litmus test for this which is
what's the one that like you don't put
as much time in and it just makes money
and it's covering all your fun ideas
real estate right do that imagine if you
actually spent time doing it all of your
time I'll tell you a story so we had a
um a lady who had a uh re like a premium
cocktail business and so she came here I
got to understand her business pretty
well um and so she was cans but she
wanted to be premium she had spent a ton
of money trying to get this out there
and fundamentally people didn't really
care too much about paying a lot of
money for canned cocktail drinks when
you could just have a tiny thing of Jack
and kzero and kind of call your flight a
flight right and so she was trying to
sell on to travel and having a tough
time she was too expensive and there was
no brand behind it so the buyers
wouldn't buy and the people on the plane
didn't care so I asked her how do you
live cuz she obviously was burning a lot
of money in this business and so she
said oh you know for years I've always
just been a flipper and I'm really good
um interior designer and so she knew how
to identify properties that had big
value ad where if she did a facelift she
could make big money and so she just did
it with penth houses so she was just
really good at that kind of like really
high end and so I was like so has this
been the thing that's made you all of
your money your whole life and she was
like yeah that's kind of how I make my
money but this this and I was like this
is a waste of time
and she was like well the interior
design flipping thing isn't scalable and
I was like let me restate this to you
real estate isn't
scalable I was like it is possibly the
most scalable business in existence you
literally add zeros you add doors it
actually gets more scalable the bigger
you get and if you're like well I don't
know if I make enough money doing just
the real estate I have to do these other
things then you need to fix the model
which means maybe you have a bigger
construction company than the size deals
you're doing which means maybe you can
support much bigger deals on the real
estate side and then the constraint
becomes capital and luckily in real
estate capital is not a hard constraint
to solve if you have a good deal the
capital will appear way back what do you
do when you and your spouse are
confused that's Lila doing that to me so
um what do you do when you and your
partner or you and your spouse are conf
confused or in Conflict around what is
the juicy know and what is the real yes
I will tell you a fun story which is
that the Allen deal of me starting Allen
the software company is the only fight
that Lea and I have ever been in and she
just pleaded with me to not do Allen and
I was like you're you're just G to
you're just going to have to see like
when we just you know crush it and the
thing is is that we did crush it but at
the expense of the other two
companies and so I just borrowed from
Peter to pay Paul and so what you don't
want is to do what I did which is I
wanted to prove myself right but I was
long-term wrong I really like to think
of kind of the question that I was
asking earlier like which one of these
things instead forget about the new
exciting juicy because there's that
everywhere and you can convin who here
knows how to spin themselves up and get
really excited about something right not
hard not hard to do but the devil you
know in a lot of ways is the devil
you've already paid all this ignorance
tax on and so a lot of you guys are
trying to jump ship when you're here but
you've already paid down all of this
time and you're just starting to see a
little bit of growth because you started
to really turn the corner on your skills
and this is the first time that you have
a more attractive woman in the red dress
and so the thing is is that every
business this is my fundamental belief
is that every business can become a
billion dollar business I've yet to see
a business that can't do
it so whether you if you were like I
want to do the salons I'm like well then
cool then go let's go do 2,000 locations
it'll take 25 years but if that's what
you want to do then we can go build a
billion dollar thing you can build
billion dollar construction companies
you just can't do that and build salons
the piece of mind I want to give you is
that either of the choices will work if
you stick with it and neither of them
will work if you don't pick um the man
who I owe a contract to all right so we
have we have two groups of products we
don't know whether to to one and then
scale that or let me ask this Lila uses
as frame a lot and this is helpful
probably for you guys which is which
problem would you rather have you can
either have the brand and director
consumer marketing problem which is what
you have in your $53 business or you can
have the B2B competitive space of being
price matched against other machines and
dealing with buyers and invoices and you
know so which of those businesses would
you rather have so I said earlier about
play it out play it out which of these
businesses would you rather have I don't
think you can have both
I mean you could I just don't think
you'll make as much money personally it
would be the D to St on the website okay
then stick with the thing that you're
good at that has made you the money up
to this point the fact that these people
came to you just say that's not the
business we're in it's shooting things
that you absolutely love that you know
you could make work I know you could
make it work and you probably love the
$20,000 checks but if you really want to
do this then you have to play it out
because the guys you're competing
against aren't thinking about selling
machines they're trying to think about
how to sell more of these $53
things now if that vanished from your
mind how much simpler is your life so
much that feeling you have right now is
what Focus feels like and you just have
to protect it at all
costs it makes it really easy to win
when you only have one thing to do